[Música]
es complicado ser uno de ellos hay que
preparar la candidatura ser patrocinado
es complicado permanecer allí porque
cada temporada hay que presentarse es
mejor no pensar ni en el tiempo ni en el
dinero invertido especialmente en
tiempos de crisis sanitaria entonces
porque las mentes creativas se dedican a
la alta costura porque es sexy y
glamoroso no sólo eso la cultura es un
laboratorio donde los diseñadores están
abiertos a múltiples campos de
posibilidades tecnología textil ciencias
cognitivas y ciencias de la comunicación
debido a la pandemia los desfiles están
siendo sustituidos por películas
es estupendo no solo mostrar la ropa
sino que nos permite mostrar el proceso
creativo
también podemos compartir el diálogo que
mantuvimos con nuestra musa muse
a través del vídeo comunicamos más
información
por supuesto es diferente pero es una
gran oportunidad
la musa que inspira a luisma nakazato se
llama loren was el antes era modelo de
moda y se convirtió en activista desde
que perdió las dos piernas tras un
síndrome de shock tóxico provocado por
un tampón higiénico
tuve dos piernas y luego teniendo las
que tengo ahora puedo decir que la
tecnología ha jugado un papel importante
para hacer la mujer en la que me he
convertido
poder moverme como lo hago correr como
lo hago realmente siento que todos vamos
a necesitar la tecnología para avanzadas
y para ser mejores en el futuro yo solo
me adelante
y soy el futuro su imán ha casado ha
desarrollado una costura sin costuras
anidados unos dentro de otros los
elementos son el resultado de una
tecnología de vanguardia que desarrolló
a partir de proteínas elaboradas su
estudio también ha desarrollado una
nueva técnica de modelización abismo
kings
las proteínas elaboradas se contraen al
sumergirse en el agua
se mueven y dan nuevas formas entonces
descubrimos que es posible controlar
estas formas con la impresión digital
wine
así que esta temporada viene con más
podemos presentar formas
tridimensionales muy complejas y muy
complicadas orgánicas que dominamos con
la técnica del bid smoking
soul that way pero es nuestra manera de
superar los límites de la alta costura
cada temporada
y con nuestra musa laura wasser somos
capaces de mostrar como respetar la
singularidad de cada cliente y
expresarla en un formato de vídeo
el mensaje completo de estar el vídeo
espero que disfruten este mensaje de
vídeo
del enfoque científico con valor de
manifiesto político pasemos a la
investigación cognitiva con valor
liberador suena incomprensible
misterioso sibilino
sofía a crochet an y los iluminará
[Música]
hoy se inspiran los trabajos de los
estudiosos que en los años 50 y 60
administraron lsd a las arañas
[Música]
y empezamos a trabajar con sustancias
estupefacientes porque era importante
ver como cualquier ser vivo podría
realmente dejarse llevar y perder el
control de sí mismo
y así con la araña llegamos a comprender
el gesto libre que se produce en cada
uno de nosotros
cada vez que intentamos expresar algo
que no sea un simple concepto
en efecto hemos redescubierto de esta
expresión liberadora este gesto de
libertad artística totalmente inesperado
y antonio así que será la de la libertad
artística sofía cristian y eligió como
decoración la galería de arte parisina
de su santa la 7 en las paredes obras
como las del artista neoexpresionista
alemán georg baselitz la película está
dirigida por el bailarín y coreógrafo
italiano jacopo godani
de marca puso en escena a las modelos
y entraron en una especie de acción que
no es la que se ve normalmente cuando se
hace una sesión de fotos de moda o un
desfile estaba hablando con el
subconsciente las chicas es realmente se
dejaron llevar sinceramente
schanzer y haya copo que era como el
hechicero lo seguían en las dirigidas y
ellas le cambiaron la mirada a través de
sus actos como se puede ver espero en
las imágenes de la película hay algo más
que la ropa ya las chicas también se
transforman en un acto artístico por sí
mismos
qué es lo que más les gusta
bueno yo odio que es lo que más odio es
difícil odiar y es difícil amar pero de
todos modos amor el amor amor el amor y
amo la libertad todo lo que odio es todo
lo que no es amor y todo lo que no es
libertad
la alta costura de su imán ha casado y
sofía cristian y es la pasión de la
investigación la exaltación del
descubrimiento e saciar la sed de
nuestros propios deseos
[Música]